you had the honor of working with cecily
so
many times what is it that what made her
so great
you know what made miss tyson because we
all called him miss tyson
yeah you knew her miss tyson thank
see my you again you know what made her
great was her tenacity
her persistence her drive
her love of life she lived life out loud
i mean she did it boldly i mean look at
her fashion you know she started off as
a model
yeah um in the 50s and 60s so
her whole sense of life was about taking
a bite out of it making a statement
being bold and being unapologetic and
that's one thing i learned from her you
know um my biggest lesson from her was
just
love life take care of yourself you know
she was a vegan
since the 1960s you know around the time
she was married to miles davis and she
said just be careful what you put inside
your body
you know you'll last longer so i learned
a lot about from her about the craft the
art of acting
the work but also how to live life how
to walk through life
do you have a favorite moment with her
because i i love that you point out
you know i think there are a lot of
people who will be confused today when
people aren't saying
well cicely i knew sis it is miss tyson
that's right that said you know if they
know her well but you know one of the
things i remember mostly was we were
doing a
a show called a movie called heatwave
about the 1965
riots and watts
[Music]
i played her grandson and she was
watching it was all during the middle of
the riots with the national guard
everywhere
and i just i was exhausted i was
emotionally drained and i could not
bring up those tears and those emotions
and she looked at me she said come here
and all she did in between takes she
just put her arms around me and hugged
me
and just held me for about a minute and
kevin hooks was directing he said i'll
just
take a time and i just welled up with
the emotions i needed for that scene and
then she tapped me on the shoulder and
said go on baby
and then we got that shot so she was
always there as as
that that that mentor that maternal
figure
and just the the ultimate exemplar of
professionalism and grace and elegance
and beauty and all of that the other
thing was
she documented everything so she was
that that fan on the set wherever she
went she brought a camera with her
so she loved to take pictures of
everybody else while everybody else
wants to take a picture of her
she were there when for both the
dedications at tyler perry studios
what was that like that night you
remember those moments the emotions when
you see
and she was like in shock that someone
would want to dedicate a sound stage to
her
you know the thing with with miss tyson
was she she had such a strong sense of
humility
she knew who she was and as i said she
walked boldly and she knew what was
uh she had expectations uh which was
good and uh
in a positive way and in that sense
you're right at tyler perry's dedication
of the studio
um that humility was on full display and
grace
and elegance of all that she personified
and presented to the world
you know we look back in time when we
think of miss jane pittman we think
i'm sounder when you think of those
the scene of her running down the road
and then you think of miss jane pitman
walking so slowly
to drink that water
[Music]
how is it that she crafted such
beautiful moments
man i gotta tell you miss jane pittman
was one of the projects that made me
want to become an actor
it's funny because you talk about miss j
the autobiography of miss jane pittman
and
in that film i think she at the end she
was like 100 years old or something like
that and you look at her character now
she was in her 30s when she
when she did that but she looked all
wrinkled and you know
aged and and you know she lived life and
look at miss tyson in 96
looks like most 50 year olds look today
just her skin and then her spirit and
all that but no but but
but you're right you know to watch her
craft that
from an audience perspective as a child
and then to have the opportunity to work
alongside her because we did a project
called mama flores family i played her
son and i had the chance to age from age
15 to 60
alongside miss tyson you know for all
that that just that whole
multi-generational
uh arc of character is is what i
what i keyed into when i watched miss
jane pittman just to play those
different
people at different stages of life and
to watch her just incrementally build
this character was
was awe-inspiring man it was it was it
was breathtaking and i i i feel
very incredibly humbled to have learned
at the at the at the feet of a master
like miss tyson
they didn't come to her early on it took
a minute
um but then finally audiences recognized
her in this second
act where she began to cross over what
was that like for her
well that's a great that's a great
question i never talked to her about
that per se but i
i i would tell you because we were
together over a span of maybe 20 25
years but there was such a
sense of gratitude such an incredible
profound sense of
gratitude that she'd done the work when
i spoke before about her professionalism
she was all about the work and focusing
on getting it done
and getting it done with excellence you
know when she won the tony award for the
trip to bountiful
in her late 80s early 90s it was a
second maybe third act for her
in the public eye but she never stopped
living she never stopped creating never
stopped
thinking and teaching you know she had
her her own school in new jersey
you know thinking about the next
generation and the next generation so
she was always very vital but in terms
of the public awareness of what she was
doing throughout through the work
as a performing artist as an actress i
think there was a second and third act
and when she won the tony award
six seven years ago for the trip to
donald that was this the beginning of
this final act that she
really started to receive all the
accolades that she reserved it was in
this time in the last several years she
received her her honorary
academy award well she should have
gotten found her many moons ago
what is the legacy of cicely tyson
legacy of cincy tyson is so much man the
legacy of cicely tyson was that she was
a trailblazer
you know when she came along when she
did in the in the 50s and 60s
uh with her contemporaries ozzy davis
cindy poitier harry belafonte
and they broke barriers for for artists
of color
and also for for women miss tyson did
and
she did it with a plum and she did it
with strength and she did it with
foresight and vision
her legacy is is is that of
of excellence
you